JJ BEHRENS: Hi, I'm JJ
Behrens and this is
Dartisans Episode Nine.
So we've got a pretty
awesome show today.
We have Johnni Winther from
Aarhus, Denmark, and he works
on Dart to JS.
Welcome to California.
How do you like the
weather out here?
JOHNNI WINTHER: Oh, it's fine.
JJ BEHRENS: It's pretty
awesome, huh?
Is it cold in Denmark at
this time of year?
JOHNNI WINTHER: No, it's
not cold, but it's
not as hot as here.
The sun is really baking here.
I was fortunate not to
bring any jackets.
Didn't need it.
JJ BEHRENS: Does the sun ever go
down at this time of year?
JOHNNI WINTHER: In Denmark?
JJ BEHRENS: In Denmark.
JOHNNI WINTHER: It does.
You have to live much
further north in
order to observe that.
That's in northern Norway, and
that is a thousand kilometers
from Denmark.
So yeah, it does go down,
at the same time as
around here, somewhat.
JJ BEHRENS: So, great, we're
going to talk to him about
Dart to JS, and we also have
Todd Turnidge, who works on
the VM team here in Mountain
View, California.
And we're going to talk about
mirrors for reflection
isolates, the embedding API,
some security stuff,
everything we could
possibly cram in.
TODD TURNIDGE: OK.
JJ BEHRENS: How do you
feel about that?
TODD TURNIDGE: Sounds good.
It's the stuff I work on,
so hopefully I'm ready
to talk about it.
JJ BEHRENS: How you feel
about Aarhus, Denmark?
TODD TURNIDGE: I've
never been.
But I like the weather
here just fine.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, we
should fix that.
So let's start off with
some Dart news.
Seth compiled these for me.
Sam McCall released
a Dart library
for Google API services.
So this is totally huge.
APIs for Blogger, AdSense
Calendar, URL Shortener and so
many more, including YouTube,
which is where I came from.
This is kind of alpha
software, but try
it out, let us know.
Go to code.google.com/
p/google-api-dart-client.
We are now up to four books
on Dart, which kind of
completely amazes me.
So go check them out.
Those are at
www.dartlang.org/books.
And we started meeting about
stuff that's going to happen
after the M1 release, so
that's pretty exciting.
We're looking forward.
Nothing concrete's happening
quite yet, but here's some
stuff we're thinking about.
We're thinking about async,
mix-ins, dynamic loading.
I know async is one of my
favorite topics, so we'll see
how that all goes.
We now have 64-bit binaries
for the SDK.
Everyone rejoice.
The editor build also includes
the 64-bit SDKs and Linux
users have been asking for this
for a while, so we're
always happy to make
our users happier.
Dart Editor now looks inside the
query method for some code
completions, and that's
pretty neat.
If the CSS selector includes a
tag name, the variable might
get some type referencing,
which--
those Dart Editor guys,
I don't know how they
do stuff like that.
For instance, if you do a query
for an input tag, the
Dart Editor might be able to
infer that the thing that
you're going to get back
is an input element.
So that's pretty cool.
Method cascades are now
implemented across the VM.
Dart to JS and the analyzer--
did you have to work on that?
TODD TURNIDGE: I did not.
JJ BEHRENS: Well, I'm not going
to talk to you about
that anymore.
So that's great for use cases
like setting up a DOM element
with a bunch of setters.
I like the fact that we're
throwing in a little bit of
syntactic niceness to solve
a bunch of use cases.
Just the write of syntax
can really
change the way you code.
Imagine if you had jQuery and
you weren't allowed to chain
methods together.
It would be very painful.
TODD TURNIDGE: Details matter
with this thing.
JJ BEHRENS: Details
matter a lot.
So if you haven't seen it yet,
Dart engineer Bob Nystrom made
a great screencast called
"Dart's Evil Plan to Make It
Easier For You to Build Web
Apps." I don't know why that's
an evil plan.
That was kind of like
the global plan.
TODD TURNIDGE: Maybe
it's aspirational.
Maybe he aspires to be evil.
He's actually a pretty
nice guy.
He'll have to work at it.
JJ BEHRENS: He's going to have
to work on being evil.
So Bob ponders if he'll make
a good supervillain.
I'm guessing not if he's trying
to make the Web better,
but we'll talk to
him about that.
So interest in web components
is heating up.
The Dart team is looking at how
to build and consume web
components with Dart.
That's super exciting, I've been
in a bunch of meetings
lately about that and--
totally awesome.
And so if you want to get up to
speed with web components,
you could watch a video from
Google I/O titled "The Web
Platform's Cutting Edge." I know
I've got to watch that,
because I'm a little bit
behind on the game.
I always focus so much
on Dart and maybe not
enough on the Web.
So we'll see.
OK, so how do you feel about
telling us about Dart to JS?
And tell us about the team in
Aarhus, because that's a long
way from here.
Who's out there?
JOHNNI WINTHER: Who's
out there.
Well, currently a lot
of people, actually.
We've put a lot of
resources, human
resources, into the project.
I'm fairly new to the
project, two months.
But now the core is six guys.
We have included some of the
guys from the I/O to work on
something that is at least
related to Dart to Js.
They tend to be put where it's
needed the most, and that
shifts as we get progress.
JJ BEHRENS: It's weird.
I think of the Glasgow Haskell
compiler, and I think of
Aarhus, with Lars Bak and V8.
There are these weird far-north
nations where
apparently people don't come
out in the winter and then
write this amazing software.
I mean, isn't that where
Linux came from?
JOHNNI WINTHER: Yeah.
Even further north.
JJ BEHRENS: So you guys just
stay inside all winter long
and just write amazing
software?
JOHNNI WINTHER: It could be
that's the reason why.
It seems to be that there's a
really great reason for making
languages in the north, both in
Denmark Norway, and Finland.
For some reason, it could be.
Well, it's not that cold,
it's just not
interesting to be outside.
JJ BEHRENS: It's not
interesting.
JOHNNI WINTHER: No, in Denmark
we do not have snow, really.
We just have gray weather, which
is cold and annoying but
mostly just uninteresting.
Well, further north you
know you have snow.
You don't do that in Denmark.
JJ BEHRENS: And so you're
working on Dart to JS?
What particular things are you
working on in Dart to JS?
How are you using it?
Are you doing something
with Dart Docs or
something like that?
JOHNNI WINTHER: Yes, my first
assignment was to
look at Dart Docs.
It was using the previous
version of the compiler, the
Frog compiler, and I've
updated it so it now
uses Dart to JS.
And now we are all clear and
can go forward on the new
compiler, on one compiler
for a language.
So that's been updated.
In that process we've got a
lot of work on the mirror
system, which I've done
together with Todd.
Actually exploring what is
needed for the compile time
part of it, seeing what
we need to inspect.
Classes and members of types and
all these relations, to be
able to produce the
documentation.
JJ BEHRENS: So I wasn't on
the team that long ago.
So can you remind newbies like
me why was it necessary to go
from Frog to Dart to JS?
What changed?
JOHNNI WINTHER: From
Frog to Dart to JS?
Well, I don't know.
JJ BEHRENS: We got
another new guy.
JOHNNI WINTHER: Because
that was prior to me.
I came in the process of saying,
we are already moving
towards that.
And I'm part of that process
of moving forward.
JJ BEHRENS: So, Mirrors.
These are for reflection, and
you guys have both been
working on mirrors.
What are mirrors going
to allow us to do?
JOHNNI WINTHER: Well, we
really have two aspects
because I look at compile
time information.
So really taking the compiler
and saying, OK, let's use that
for a mirror system.
And the thing you can ask there
is, of course, if we
have a walk through with the
libraries, inspect what types
are there, what functions and
variables we have, and go into
the types and look at what
members we have.
All these static elements.
Currently we do not go into
methods, so it's only the
interface of things.
So that's the compile time
notion, and the runtime part
is really Todd's side.
So he's come from the other side
of it with all you can do
when a program is running.
The compile time doesn't
have that part.
JJ BEHRENS: Todd, tell us
about mirrors running.
TODD TURNIDGE: Sure.
Well, we've got all the
declaration kind of stuff that
Johnni's been talking about.
And we've also got the ability
to do some things you'd
expect, like invoke a method, or
create a new object with a
constructor, or get the value
of a field, or set the value
of a field.
These are all pretty much the
primitive operations that you
can do when you're programming,
it's just here
you're doing it reflectively.
There's a lot of interesting
applications you can build
once you have these things, and
it's really something we
need to have in a language.
I've done this so far, I've
implemented it in the VM.
So you can import dart:mirrors
in the VM and get access to
the mirror system and start
playing with it.
But we still have yet to do it
in Dart to JS at a runtime.
There's a lot of things we have
planned, too, but those
are in the future.
At least to modify code, load
new classes, or modify
functions or things like that.
JJ BEHRENS: I guess that's the
challenge of trying to support
multiple environments, but it's
definitely worth it once
we can start writing all of our
applications, both client
and server, in Dart.
And we'll have the Dart VM.
And the browser's kind of a
different environment, and
hopefully we'll get the Dart
VM integrated there, but in
the meantime it's really
beneficial to get the isolates
in both places.
TODD TURNIDGE: The
mirrors, rather.
JJ BEHRENS: Sorry, the
mirrors, thank you.
TODD TURNIDGE: Looking
ahead, yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: So I was talking
to the AngularJS guys about
reflection, and one of the
things they used reflection
for was, they will have a
top-level function in
JavaScript and then they will
just list a bunch of arguments
that have standard names, and
whatever arguments that you
request will automatically be
passed in as a way of doing
dependency injection.
I don't think that we're trying
to do exactly like
AngularJS, but I think that
there's going to be a lot of
people out there in the world
that are going to use mirrors
to do interesting things.
TODD TURNIDGE: It's great for
building frameworks where you
can't necessarily anticipate
what's going to happen.
So you need to be able to
inspect it and do something.
Maybe like a testing system,
where you need to go and find
all the test functions and call
them in the order they're
declared or something
like that.
Mirrors is perfect for that.
Back when I hacked on Python
a little bit, DER.
DER is very helpful.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, yeah, DER.
How do you live without DER?
TODD TURNIDGE: How do you
live without DER, right.
So now you can write DER with
mirrors, if you want.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty awesome.
I know that a lot of Ruby
programmers who are going to
be coming in to Dart, they
love the metaprogramming
stuff, so as soon as we get the
mirrors, they're going to
be all over that stuff.
Pretty exciting.
So, isolates.
How did you get stuck
working on isolates?
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, when
I started on the VM team
probably about a year ago, they
asked me to work on the
embedding API.
And it turns out that one of the
primary things an embedder
needs to do is interact with
the isolate system.
So I ended up going from there
and working on the isolate
implementation inside
the VM and changing
some aspects of that.
That's how I got into that.
JJ BEHRENS: I personally love
isolates because I coded
Erlang long ago and I've always
thought that was just
the right way to
do concurrency.
I've never been a big fan
of shared mutable state
concurrency, so that's
definitely something that
draws me to the language.
So when I've given Dart talks
before, I talk about isolates
kind of at a high level of what
they are, but can you
talk a little bit about how
isolates are implemented in
terms of Unix processes,
Unix threads, all of
that kind of stuff?
TODD TURNIDGE: So we basically
have a pool of threads.
And at any given point when an
isolate's running, it will be
assigned a thread, and
it'll own that thread
until it stops running.
When it stops running, it'll
release the thread back to the
pool, and somebody else
will be welcome to
take it at that point.
So I've got this thread pool.
So you can have like 1,000
isolates and if only 10 of
them are running, you'll
have 10 threads going.
And if it bumps up, we'll
actually sort of reclaim
threads slowly over time,
if they're not in use.
We'll just say, ah, maybe
we need fewer.
We just sort of adjust it
a bit as we go along.
JJ BEHRENS: So the interesting
thing about isolates compared
to Erlang processes is that
Erlang processes are a lot
more lightweight.
You could have 10,000 of them,
whereas you're not going to
have 10,000 isolates currently
running because you're limited
by the number of threads.
But instead we have this other
business where we do a lot of
asynchronous stuff within
a particular isolate.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah.
So we're still at early releases
of Dart, and we have
a lot of freedom in the future
to change how we implement
them on an underlying system.
And we are working on scaling
the isolates.
We have somebody in the group
who's trying to reduce memory
footprint for each isolate by
doing things like sharing some
of the space that's used for
the code across them, and a
variety of things like that.
We're trying to reduce our
per-isolate footprint as much
as we can, because really we
aspire to have isolates feel
very lightweight.
And we're working
towards that.
JJ BEHRENS: So do you think
that in the future we will
continue to have this idea
of where we have somewhat
slightly heavier-weight isolates
but lots of things
running asynchronously within
a particular isolate, or do
you think--
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, our APIs
are all designed around
asynchrony, so I don't
anticipate that going away.
I don't know for sure.
JJ BEHRENS: So can you tell
me a little bit about how
isolates are going to work
on multi-core systems?
Because I remember in Erlang,
until OTP came out, they had a
hard time running Erlang
processes across multiple
CPUs, and it was only
when OTP came out
that that was possible.
For us, we're going to be able
to run on multiple CPUs with
separate threads
already, right?
TODD TURNIDGE: It just works.
My box has 12 CPUs, or some
number of CPUs like that and
it'll happily run on them.
Yours, I can tell.
JJ BEHRENS: So can I
just say that the
concurrency problem is solved?
Like, hereon, like I'm going
to stamp it and blog it and
say, We solved the concurrency
problem?
TODD TURNIDGE: I don't know.
You have to write down what
the concurrency problem is
before I can state
that it's solved.
It seems like a big thing to
say, the concurrency problem.
But yeah, no, it'll
happily run on--
it just uses the OS threads,
and so whatever
they'll do, it'll do.
JJ BEHRENS: You're right,
the concurrency
problem has many facets.
I know that we just hired a guy
and he was working on SIMD
integration into Dart, and that
excites me because SIMD
is its own different type of
concurrency that doesn't
really fit.
But being able to have multiple
approaches to
concurrency, different tools
for different problems.
TODD TURNIDGE: Sure.
JJ BEHRENS: So you also said
you started working on the
embedding API.
Tell us about that.
TODD TURNIDGE: So the embedding
API, honestly, it
sort of grew.
When I got to the project,
they'd sort of built an API
that was sufficient for letting
Dart VM do what it
needed to do.
And so it wasn't necessarily
very consistent and it was a
little heavyweight in terms of
how, when you get back a
result, you had to check it for
an error before you could
get a handle out.
And so since then we've done a
lot of work to try to make it
a little bit more consistent,
a little easier to use.
For example, you get back
error handles from these
functions, and you can just
inspect those rather than
having to go through
this two-step
process we used to have.
And we're also doing things to
try to make the API more
fleshed out.
For example, Mirrors is a great
forcing function for the
embedding API, because when
you're doing reflection, you
have to be able to do anything,
a lot of things.
And if you can't do them in the
embedding API, then it's
really not complete.
So we've been using it that
way, as a sort of forcing
function to make us be honest
and make the embedding API is
powerful as it needs to be.
JJ BEHRENS: So I tend to fly
around and give a lot of
talks, and the interesting thing
is, almost all the time
I've spent learning Dart
has been on airplanes.
And so I read all of your
C++ code on an airplane.
And the thing that stuck out the
most to me was, first of
all, it's in C++.
I'm so used to languages like
Python and Perl, where the
extension API is in C. Do you
have any comments about having
it be in C++ instead of C?
TODD TURNIDGE: Well,
the embedding API--
dart_api.h is a C file.
So people will interact with it
through C. But internally
in VM, we do develop in C++.
And this is a strange thing
about doing VM development, is
that you think about one
language all the time, but you
program in another language
all the time.
I remember back on other VMs
I've worked on, it was sort of
like you're constantly being
asked psychology questions,
but you're just thinking about
neurons all the time.
You're thinking about the brain,
but you're thinking
about it a different way.
So for me I program about
Dart all day.
I don't program in
Dart as much.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, and you don't
get a chance to use the
Dart Editor.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, except
for when I'm writing
regression tests or something.
I have to make it fail in just
the way this person managed to
make it fail.
They send me some sort of
concurrent program that's
selling tickets at a stadium--
if you're watching, hello--
and so I have to take that,
whittle it down to a test
case, and make sure we don't
ever break that way again.
JJ BEHRENS: Now, wait a second,
I thought all test
cases would have to be phrased
in the form of a dining
philosopher's problem.
TODD TURNIDGE: Oh, yeah.
But they're not grabbing
for chopsticks anymore.
JJ BEHRENS: No?
Well, if you guys have
concurrency problems, please
make sure to format them as
dining philosophers--
TODD TURNIDGE: No.
Please don't.
Send them to me nice
and short.
JJ BEHRENS: Nice and short.
Yeah, here's the nice
and short code.
There's a bug in there.
Find it.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: So I'm guessing that
we've probably started
out in C++ because large-block
did V8, and Chrome itself is
in C++ just like every other
browser out there.
So you also wanted to talk
to us about security.
And we wanted to be secure by,
like, obscurity or something,
so I didn't even put that in
the description for today.
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, you know,
since we have a public bug
database, people are basically
able to look at whatever
issues we're working on.
They can see the security fix
that we did, they can look at
the commits.
It's all out there.
It's an open source project.
JJ BEHRENS: But it's blocked
in Russia, right?
TODD TURNIDGE: Oh yeah, we don't
let any of them read it.
No offense.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm Russian.
TODD TURNIDGE: I'm supposed
to remember to
look at this camera.
So the security inside
of the VM.
There's just these problems that
you make all the time,
which is basically numbers
are not on a line,
they're on a loop.
If you go too far in
one direction,
you go negative again.
It's like you get the high score
on an old video game
machine, and you flip it.
You've got 100,000, now you've
got a negative 100,000.
JJ BEHRENS: That's happened
to me a lot.
TODD TURNIDGE: And you don't
want this to happen when
somebody's allocating
an array.
If somebody says, I want an
array that's 500 million
elements long, you don't want
that to turn into an array
that's two elements long because
suddenly then you
don't allocate the right amount
of space, they can
overwrite your stack, they can
do all sorts of bad things.
So we've been doing stuff in the
VM to try to be a lot more
careful about how we handle
integer overflow conditions,
especially around allocation.
So I've been getting to learn
about that kind of stuff and
put in lots of special
tests to make sure--
you know there's a cliff over
here, and you don't want walk
off the end of the cliff.
JJ BEHRENS: And you also don't
want to check every two steps.
TODD TURNIDGE: You don't want
to check every two steps.
Some people develop these secure
integer libraries and
use those, but we know that
there are certain places where
we get numbers from the users
that are not trusted.
We trust our users, but, you
know, not all of them.
JJ BEHRENS: Not all of them.
TODD TURNIDGE: Just kidding.
So you just want to make sure
that you validate these inputs
and that you don't do anything
especially bad with them.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm grateful for
when the VM takes care of that
kind of stuff because I remember
my assembly language
days, and it's like, I don't
want to think about overflow.
I want to be like a scheme
programmer with infinitely
sized integers and never
have to think about
that kind of stuff.
So any time you guys
could save me.
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, once you're
in the Dart language,
we have big integers, right?
Your integers aren't going
to overflow in
the language itself.
It's just when you're
programming about Dart, where
you're interfacing with
the C++ code.
We need to be aware of the
machine we're running on and
the realities of living
on a loop.
JJ BEHRENS: I assume you've seen
third-party contributions
to Dart, in terms
of extensions.
What are your favorite
extensions?
TODD TURNIDGE: No, that's part
of programming about Dart
instead of programming
in Dart.
I don't have a favorite
extension at this point.
I have to defer to you.
What's your favorite
extension?
JJ BEHRENS: I'm kind of old
school, so I heard that we had
a MySQL driver, and I know that
everyone else has moved
on to MongoDB and everything
else like that, but there's
something that makes me feel,
I don't know, like all the
world is right when
I have a MySQL.
TODD TURNIDGE: Nostalgic?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, nostalgic.
It's like, OK I will never get
stuck, because I have MySQL.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah,
it's classic.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah,
if nothing else.
You talked about the embedding
API versus the extension API.
Maybe not everyone gets
the difference.
Tell me about the difference
between those two things.
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, the
difference would
be not much, honestly.
People basically use the
embedding API for their
extensions.
We originally wrote it as an
embedding API, we thought of
it that way, and then extensions
were added later.
It seems to work.
People can do things like, they
can create ports that
look like Dart ports as far as
the program's concerned, but
are backed by a C function,
or a C++
function, or their library.
So it allows them to create
a sort of fake--
you could almost call it
like a native isolate.
And so people do that
kind of thing.
JJ BEHRENS: It's pretty cool.
I know that Lua's well known
for having a really nice
embedding API, and of course
Python has an embedding API,
but for some reason there's this
conception in the world
that Lua's easier to embed,
and so a lot more C
programmers end up
embedding Lua.
Now, how important
is that to us?
I mean, how often do you think
we're going to see video games
written in C++ that embed
the Dart engine?
TODD TURNIDGE: You know, I
don't know I think we're
making a nice language.
It's a language that I
would like to use.
And so I could imagine that
other people will want to use
it to in their applications.
But right now our embedding
API tends to make some
decisions that allow a
lot of flexibility on
the part of the embedder.
We allow them to provide
callbacks that customize a lot
of different aspects of how
they interact with it.
And so we try not to make
a lot of assumptions.
But that means that there'll be
a little bit more work up
front, in terms of providing,
OK, here's what you need to do
to create an isolate, here's
what you need to do
this, you need to
pass on these callbacks.
So if you're embedding it,
there's some setup, and we
haven't really written a good
document yet about embedding
the Dart VM.
I think we should.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, but the whole
effort, I think, is
really good.
I remember reading this long
article about Smalltalk, and
one of the challenges that
they had in the Smalltalk
world is that it wasn't so easy
to integrate with the
rest of the world.
And I think that one of the
reasons why Python was so
successful is because they
had a good extension API.
Python is a glue language
for all these libraries,
extensions written in C. Do you
think we're going to be
able to get to the point where
Dart on the server is a
really, really nice language
with lots of extensions, and
this is a softball question--
TODD TURNIDGE: Honestly, having
embedded Python myself
in a previous life, there's some
things that we have to
offer, like we don't have to
keep track of reference count.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, that's
fantastic.
TODD TURNIDGE: I recall that
when I was embedding Python, I
had to always know, was this
reference borrowed or stolen?
And here a small error can't
result in your program
crashing that way.
You rely on a garbage collector
to collect your
garbage for you, and that's
nice, from an embedder's
standpoint.
I really appreciate that.
Another thing was, Python has
this global interpreter lock--
JJ BEHRENS: Really?
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: I think 50 blog
posts just went up
about it right now.
TODD TURNIDGE: OK, sorry.
But I really like the feel of
using that language and
embedding it, and I hope that
we can make a language that
other people want to embed in
their things, and I hope to be
successful there.
That would make me feel really
good, if we have a lot of
users for the embedding API, and
if we cut off some these
sharp corners and make it a lot
easier for them to do they
want to do, that'd
be really nice.
JJ BEHRENS: Now, are you working
on a special format
for the documents that make it
easier to read on a plane?
Because I'd be down with
that, you know.
So you worked on the Dartium
integration of the VM?
TODD TURNIDGE: I work a lot with
the people on the Dartium
team, yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: So do you have a
feel for how difficult it was
to integrate?
TODD TURNIDGE: They already had
something running when I
joined the team.
So what I'll do is I'll go along
and I'll break their
build all the time.
Not quite.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
your job, right.
TODD TURNIDGE: I want to make
incompatible changes to the
API to make it better.
And now is easier than it's
ever going to be in the
future, so we've gone through
and made lots of
incompatible changes.
And then we go and have to make
sure that we coordinate
with them to make sure that they
can get their changes in
as quickly as possible.
JJ BEHRENS: I like to make
incompatible changes to the
API because I'm in developer
relations and that's how I
relate to people.
TODD TURNIDGE: Is by telling
how you've broken them?
JJ BEHRENS: Yes, it's like,
Hey, I broke your API.
Nice to meet you.
Let's talk.
TODD TURNIDGE: Right now we're
in a time of a lot of change
in the project, and we're trying
to break things now, so
we can get things on a more
nice, stable platform going
forward from M1.
JJ BEHRENS: So another thing.
Getting back to the isolates,
I know that we were talking
today in a meeting about using
synchronous isolates within
the single UI thread in order
to talk to JavaScript.
JavaScript interoperability.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah,
we're working on
this stuff right now.
I'm not part of those
discussions.
They're all happening
in Denmark.
Clearly JavaScript
interoperability is something
a lot of people ask about, it's
important to a lot of
people, and we need to have a
really clear story about that.
I'm not part of the group
working on that, but we want
to make it a very natural thing
to be able to reuse code
that you already have
that's useful.
Part of getting acceptance, is
making something that people
can interface with the blocks
they've already got.
JJ BEHRENS: So it'll be
interesting to see how it goes
because I know we have this idea
of running isolates in
separate web workers, but we
also have this idea of
synchronous isolates to isolate
various JavaScript
widgets or whatever so that
they're segmented.
So we have this idea of an
isolate, and it'll be
interesting to see what
happens with all the
different use cases.
So I know we have some
questions, so
let me get to them.
What kind of new tooling
libraries could we see
emerging from the Dart team
when Mirrors has landed?
Crystal ball time.
What do you think?
New tooling libraries.
JOHNNI WINTHER: Well, one thing
that's been added as
part of the job Todd and I have
done, or I'm doing now,
is really the ability to inspect
the static part of the
code, so it feels natural to
do something there that you
can actually inspect code.
Run the compiler and
inspect the class
hierarchy, and that stuff.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, you can
write custom analyzers on top
of that kind of thing, and
all sorts of good stuff.
JOHNNI WINTHER: Yeah.
And to start with, it's
an external structure.
So that's really being able to
browse the class hierarchy,
which is a good thing, being
able to find stuff.
If you don't find the Dart doc
good enough, you can actually
write one that's better
on top of this.
JJ BEHRENS: I know we also kind
of answered this earlier
when you were talking about
testing tools, and I was
talking about AngularJS's
approach
to dependency injection.
I think it actually opens
up a lot of worlds.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yes, it's really
an important part of
today's programming languages,
being able to reflect.
We need it.
JJ BEHRENS: So will isolates
support transferable objects
like Chrome with the type of
arrays in the workers?
I heard that we were
switching to CORBA.
Some people out there going
to be laughing.
They're C++ programmers.
TODD TURNIDGE: I didn't
hear that.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, well,
maybe it's not true.
TODD TURNIDGE: I talked to
Carl on my team, who'd
probably be the one who'd be
responsible for handling that
kind of thing, and he said the
answer to that is yes.
JJ BEHRENS: Yes.
TODD TURNIDGE: He said
probably yes.
JJ BEHRENS: Wow, that's
a tough one.
Because it's like you--
what about the dynamic
code loading, and--
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, the
transferable objects, or whatever.
JJ BEHRENS: So are there still
plans to spawn isolates on the
client from the server?
If so, will low-latency,
low-bandwidth use on
the goals for that?
Will it use web sockets
for the communication?
TODD TURNIDGE: I don't know how
we're going to implement
this, particularly
in the browser.
I work on the VM a lot.
But I do know that we are
looking at evolving the
isolate API quite a
bit going forward.
And part of that would most
certainly involve being able
to interact with an isolate
that's remote.
Being able to name this isolate
and talk to it,
respond to failures.
That's a huge thing that
actually I probably should've
said earlier about the isolate
API is that right now you have
an isolate that you've spawned,
and it goes and dies.
And what happens?
Well, right now if you're inside
standalone VM running
on a command line, it takes
down your whole VM.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh!
TODD TURNIDGE: Does
that seem like--
JJ BEHRENS: No!
TODD TURNIDGE: --a good
way to build a system?
JJ BEHRENS: You're gonna
fix that, right?
TODD TURNIDGE: We're
going to fix that.
So we need to be able to handle
the fact I'm talking to
a port but the port is closed.
Why is it closed?
How can I respond to this?
What do I want to do?
Do I want to shut myself down,
do I want to shut down some
other isolates?
I'm going to need to be able to
interact with isolates in a
more nuanced way, more like the
way that, say, you could
do in Erlang, or something
like that.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I was just
about to ask you, are we going
to do something like Erlang OTP
where we have isolates on
multiple machines talking to
each other and failovers and
watchdogs, all that
kind of stuff?
TODD TURNIDGE: I can't speak
to that exact architecture,
but we certainly need to
solve that problem.
JJ BEHRENS: Are you going
to have it by next week?
TODD TURNIDGE: No.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh.
Well.
Geez.
TODD TURNIDGE: OK.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
Great.
Well, we've circled
around this a lot.
What are the differences
between Erlang
actors and Dart isolates?
Are there any plans to
build Erlang OTP-like
framework on Dart?
TODD TURNIDGE: Wow,
sounds familiar.
Certainly they have a lot
of good features.
We should be looking at our
isolates right now, they're
pretty bare-bones, and we should
be thinking about what
it is that we need to add so
that we can build reliable
systems on top of
these things.
JJ BEHRENS: Now, I'm generally
pretty forgiving about syntax,
and I like coding in a lot of
languages, but I do happen to
like Dart's syntax a little
bit better than Erlang.
TODD TURNIDGE: I haven't
programmed in Erlang, so I
can't, you know.
Besides, I program about Dart.
JJ BEHRENS: I would
have to say that--
I always joke that Erlang has
syntax that only a compiler
writer could love.
So most of my programming work
is developing either COM
server DLLs or .net class
libraries, exposing a certain
interface to external Windows
applications.
Would you think it is feasible
to wrap the Dart VM such that
it could be used for this?
Oh, what a perfect question.
TODD TURNIDGE: I think it could
be feasible to embed the
Dart VM and use it in a variety
of contexts, yes.
I mean, we haven't written a
nice guide for how to do it
step by step, but our code's all
public, so you can look at
how we're doing it in a variety
of projects right now.
Particularly the standalone
VM is probably
the simplest embedding.
If you look at how we're doing
it there, and you're clever,
you might be able to figure
out to do it on your own.
JJ BEHRENS: So knowing that
you code in EMX, I have a
suspicion you're gonna have a
hard time debugging the Visual
Studio build problems that are
inevitably going to come up.
TODD TURNIDGE: No comment.
JJ BEHRENS: So how would Dart
handle environment-specific
implementations of libraries,
e.g., select native extensions
in the VM and pure Dart
in the browser?
I kind of have an
answer to this.
What do you think?
You guys have any answers?
TODD TURNIDGE: I mean, we've
been thinking about how to
share our core library coda a
lot lately and mark certain
parts of it as being external
and provided by
a particular platform.
We're trying to share as
much code as possible.
And we have actually sort of a
library unification project
going on right now where there's
a Dart to JS version
of this, and the VM version
of this, and
that's clearly not great.
We'd rather have one version
that had as much code shared
as we possibly could so people
know what to look at.
They say, I want to know
what a list does.
It's nice to be able to
go look at a list,
see what a list is.
And then we can patch some tiny
little native bits in the
VM, or in Dart to JS,
or what have you.
JJ BEHRENS: I don't have a
perfect answer for this, but I
do believe they're working on
this in Aarhus, the big
library reorg.
JOHNNI WINTHER: One of the
things about this is, as you
said, we currently have several
implementations, and
actually with that, several
interfaces of those
implementations.
And the first step is really to
say, well, we should have
one interface of this.
Saying how do we have an
implementation for this, even
though it might have one
interface for several
implementations.
Currently it's just several
And depending on where you
point, and that's really
depending on who you talk to,
do you talk to Dart to JS do
you to talk to the VM, do
you talk to the Editor.
It might actually say something
that is different.
And we have to get a unified
answer on this, so we know
that, well, this is the
interface for it.
How and when to implement it,
that would be the problem for
us, but it's one unified
interface.
So that's where we're going
on, for those, and that's
really pushed up front now.
JJ BEHRENS: Well, I'm
disappointed that you guys
didn't wait for it to be perfect
before shipping it.
So when will we have feature
parity when using mirrors on
the VM versus Dart to JS?
Can we get, like,
a calendar date?
Like, we're down to the hour?
TODD TURNIDGE: I don't know if
we've really started the
runtime implementation
of Mirrors.
JOHNNI WINTHER: I haven't seen
any, so I don't think we have
done anything.
There could be some work on just
providing runtime type
information, which is really
the startup point for it.
But there's a whole lot of
mechanism that has to be
implemented just to do the
compile time interface.
TODD TURNIDGE: Do we plan
on doing it eventually?
JOHNNI WINTHER: I haven't heard
any schedule on the
Mirrors, on any scheduling
of when.
I think in time, yes,
but when, no.
TODD TURNIDGE: I can give
you a little bit
of background here.
Just sort of on a human level,
what happened is we knew we
wanted Mirrors.
And the guy I sit next to is
the guy who basically--
Gilad Bracha, he does a lot of
our language specification
work, but he also is very
interested in reflection.
And so he'd come up
with an interface.
He said, we should have
this interface.
So I said, OK, let's implement
it on the VM and let it bake a
little bit and see
if we like it.
And so we're still in that,
like, baking phase, and we
haven't gotten to the, everybody
else wants to eat
this pie, we should put in the
Dart to JS oven phase yet.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
I guess that theory is a lot
better than my theory.
TODD TURNIDGE: But I can take
that as feedback to the team,
that perhaps we should
think about when
we're going to do this.
I don't know, I don't know, we
can't promise, but it's a good
idea to have it, parity would
be useful, because otherwise
it's hard to write code.
JJ BEHRENS: It'll come, it's
just a matter of time.
My theory was that it's
summer in Denmark.
Everyone wants to go outside.
And we have to wait until it
gets a little bit colder
before all these things will
just come out, all of them, at
the same time.
JOHNNI WINTHER: There is this
issue, that everyone has been
away now, and we are all coming
back, and I'm sure
we're going to be much more
fluent on things, and much
more work done.
JJ BEHRENS: And maybe a new
kernel as well, a new
operating system.
JOHNNI WINTHER: Oh, you never
know what happens.
JJ BEHRENS: So, hello, guys.
I've just come in.
I don't know if you already
talked for the plan for UI
extensions that compete
with extJS or GWT.
So it looks like we're going
to be doing a lot of stuff
with web components in the
future, that's definitely
something we're looking into a
lot, and it'll be interesting
to see web components, be they
written in JavaScript or Dart,
working together and I think
web components might be the
place where we have
a nice interface.
TODD TURNIDGE: That'd be nice.
JJ BEHRENS: So any plans for
native animation and
interpolation like jQuery?
I don't think that these guys
would answer this question,
but I think this might
be a perfect case--
I don't know if we're doing
it, but that sounds like a
really good thing to have as
a third party library.
And so you, out there,
please code it.
And the next question, can
server-side Dart code call
server-side Java APIs?
TODD TURNIDGE: Well, we do have
the native extension API.
They could presumably embed
a Java VM, and--
JJ BEHRENS: I know people who
do this kind of stuff, and I
always think they're crazy when
they embed multiple VMs.
That sounds painful.
TODD TURNIDGE: Right now our
primary interface is from Dart
to C. But I don't know
in the future.
Right now, clearly, there's no
out-of-the-box solution for--
there's no off-the-shelf
solution that does
this kind of thing.
JJ BEHRENS: I have
a suspicion.
Of course the Dart
has its own VM.
It is not the JVM, and so
embedding those things, it's
not trivial.
And I think that maybe a better
plan is to do something
outside of the space, like
a REST web service or
something like that.
OK, so we're out of questions
and I know that we're going to
get kicked out of the studio
pretty soon because
Wednesday's like the busiest
day, and like
everyone wants to have--
TODD TURNIDGE: I thought of
one more thing I'd like to
tell people.
Look for a new stack trace
format from the VM.
JJ BEHRENS: Wow.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, so far
the stack traces have been
very, very ugly.
They have lots of extra
characters and are
really hard to read.
And I checked in today a new
version of stack traces, so as
your programs crash it should
be more pleasant.
JJ BEHRENS: You know, I've
never seen a stack that I
really thought, wow, this
is just pleasant.
TODD TURNIDGE: A beautiful,
pleasant-- no, it isn't
pleasant, it's never pleasant
to get a stack trace, but at
least they should be legible.
So I decided that needed
to change.
I'll let you go back to
what you were saying.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, well, that's
great, and especially C++ back
traces, like--
TODD TURNIDGE: They
can be bad.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, just
a little bit.
TODD TURNIDGE: But you know,
we were exposing internal
names for things, so they'd see
things in the stack traces
that wouldn't necessarily even
make sense from a Dart
language perspective.
It's really important that the
stack trace actually be
something that you can
understand from a Dart
language level and it have nice
white space in it so you
can parse it with your eyes.
JJ BEHRENS: OK, so for you C++
programmers out there, this is
the guy to thank.
TODD TURNIDGE: No, no, not the
C++, the Dart stack trace.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, Dart
stack trace.
TODD TURNIDGE: I'm talking
about the Dart
language stack traces.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, wow.
OK, well.
Now we can all love you.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah,
that's the plan.
JJ BEHRENS: So that's
fantastic.
Thank you guys for coming.
This was a great show.
Thank you for visiting,
and thank you for
taking all of my questions.
We will see you guys next time,
two weeks from now.
We're still debating
on which day.
We might be moving to Thursdays
in the morning.
I know that a lot of Europeans
missed this, but this was the
only time we had free in the
studio, but we'll announce our
next episode of Dartisans.
Thanks a lot, guys.